[Music]
on this monday night manhunt after a
mass murder
the two brothers accused of a deadly
rampage in saskatchewan one suspect is
still on the loose why would you come in
and
kill an innocent person the fond
memories of the victims
chilling comparisons to the nova scotia
massacre there are sort of eerie
parallels the lessons the rcmp have
learned
up in flames the race to extinguish
raging wildfires in a canadian national
park and california and taking the
reigns we will deliver britain's next
prime minister and her connection to
canada
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening we begin with breaking news
tonight from saskatchewan police say one
of two brothers wanted in the stabbing
deaths of 10 people has been found dead
the other brother is still at large
31-year-old damian sanderson was found
dead near a house being investigated on
the james smith cree nation he was found
in a grassy area with wounds police say
are not believed to be self-inflicted
the search is still on for his brother
miles sanderson who may be wounded
miles sanderson
damien's brother
may have sustained injuries
this has not been
confirmed but we do want the public to
know this because there is a possibility
he may seek medical attention
even if he is injured it does not mean
he is not still dangerous
global's heather urex west joins us from
weldon tonight one of the communities
where the attacks took place
heather this is quite the development
yeah farah it will no doubt
come as some comfort to the two
communities that have just been through
such a terrifying ordeal but they are
still grieving the losses of ten people
nine from the nearby community of james
smith create nation and the tenth victim
from here in weldon saskatchewan a tiny
hamlet of just 200 people where everyone
knows everyone and tonight everyone is
grieving the loss of a beloved friend
and neighbor
who is believed to have been in the
wrong place at the wrong time
this is like nothing people in weldon
saskatchewan have ever experienced not
here so close to home
police investigators combing through 13
different crime scenes most on the james
smith cree nation but neighbors here in
nearby weldon say this scene was the
home of wes peterson their friend a long
time resident known by everyone in town
and deeply loved when i found out my
friend was
killed
i just
hit the ground ruby works new peterson
for most of her life i known him since i
was a little girl
he was like an uncle to me why would you
come in and
kill an
innocent person who didn't do anything
he didn't deserve this neighbors
describe peterson as a kind and
gentleman who like to keep a close watch
on their community you're the sweetest
old man like just the kindest guy and
you
everyone will remember him and it'll be
love that comes from it and not hate so
that's kind of the one thing that you
take from it he was our man that was
down
at coffee row he opened our coffee row
every morning monday to saturday
neighbors suspect that may have been how
peterson was attacked with damien
sanderson now confirmed dead his brother
miles remains the subject of a
province-wide manhunt charged with three
counts of first degree murder one count
of attempted murder and almost certainly
more charges to follow at 1 17 p.m today
it was confirmed by saskatchewan rcmp
forensic investigation section that the
deceased is damian sanderson
his body was located outdoors in a
heavily grassed area in proximity to a
house that was being examined
we can confirm he has visible injuries
these injuries are not believed to be
self-inflicted after the eruption of
violence that left 10 people dead and 18
injured
generations of families believed torn
apart
some needing air ambulances to get them
to hospital for urgent care we're shaken
up in our small town can you imagine
what james smith feels like
with all those people that are
killed over there and and wounded and
stuff you know hurt the james smith cree
nation is asking for privacy as the
people there come to terms with so much
trauma and loss
both communities now facing impossible
grief with so many questions surrounding
those believed responsible a neighbor
now the subject of a province-wide
manhunt people here now locking their
doors their sense of security forever
changed i'm terrified i'm terrified to
go to sleep
i'm terrified they're gonna come back
and
kill again
so communities in central saskatchewan
are rightly still on edge a manhunt
continues four miles sanderson and
police
while police say that he may have
injuries people are not
to take this lightly that even with
injuries he is still believed to be very
dangerous they're just letting the
public know that he may seek medical
attention there's a number of police
from all over the prairies that have
come to the region to help with this
investigation combing through the 13
crime scenes trying to find the answers
for these two communities that are still
reeling
coming to grips with such incredible
losses and of course even after the
manhunt uh ends
and the investigation continues the long
road towards healing will will
continue with with so many uh funerals
in the days ahead pharah
okay heather your us west thank you so
much for your coverage heathers and
weldon saskatchewan and police in
saskatchewan have issued another
province-wide dangerous personal alert
unrelated to what we just reported this
one was a shots-fired call at a first
nations community in northern
saskatchewan again police say this
incident is not connected to the deadly
stabbing rampage this alert was issued
by spiritwood rcmp detachment
police say the initial call came from
the wichiken lake first nation several
armed suspects are still at large and
may be traveling in a dark red 2000 ford
mustang police telling people to shelter
in place and to call 9-1-1 if they see
anything suspicious
a lot goes into executing an intense
search mass cooperation is critical
today saskatchewan premier scott mo gave
an update on what the province is doing
to help
we have supplemented rcmp and local
police resources with additional
provincial protective services staff
from the province and coordinated
increased security presence at area
hospitals where many victims families
are gathering and we continue to offer
the full support and resources of the
province in this investigation
we want to bring in our ottawa bureau
chief mercedes stevenson now she's been
digging into the coordination of
resources mercedes first how does law
enforcement make sure that that all the
bases are covered here
so far i've been speaking to individuals
who are working both on this case and
who have worked on previous very high
profile manhunts in canada to find out
how they put this together and there's
really two aspects technology and eyes
out and those eyes of course are human
eyes of both police officers and those
in the community let's start with
technology they'll be looking for miles
sanderson's uh cell phone is it giving
off a signature is it on is it bouncing
off of cell towers they will look for
access to his social media accounts who
he might have been connected to on there
anything he's posted in the past that
might indicate where he has contacts or
where he could travel to there's also
things like aerial surveillance we heard
the rcmp talking about aircraft they can
use drones at night they have night
vision goggles and infrared that can
pick up heat signatures but those things
tend to be more useful when you're
talking about a rural search what we're
talking about right now based on what
the police are telling us is an urban
search that's more complicated when it
comes to some of this technology and
that's where the human aspect really
comes in finding people who know miles
sanderson who might be sheltering him
looking for cars or people who might be
known to him in a neighborhood entering
a house any signs of suspicious activity
and that's why police are encouraging
people if you see something that you
think looks a little bit off call it in
a number of folks i talked to who worked
on past manhunts say those little tiny
things in the past seem to come back
later and often could have been a moment
that makes or breaks a manhunt mercedes
what about planning i mean how much will
officers be looking into whether the
suspects coordinated things ahead of
time
well this is a big question what's the
motive and we don't have an answer there
because that might speak to how well
planned this was and that could tell us
for example does miles sanderson have
changes of clothes on him changes of
vehicles did he have things set up the
fact that his brother is dead damien
sanderson could change the police
calculus one person is harder to find
than two but he also has less help i
spoke to retired sergeant major
sebastian lavoie of the rcmp about what
police will be doing to try to close the
loop around this individual how do we
tighten up the net around them so that
everything becomes difficult getting
food becomes difficult going to a
location becomes difficult speaking to
friends becomes difficult
and farah that is exactly what police
will be trying to do tonight all right
thanks mercedes
as we learn more about the deadly
violence in saskatchewan it became more
and more apparent that police had
learned some lessons in communicating
with the public from other canadian
tragedies as ross lord reports police in
saskatchewan were quick to issue expand
and update a string of public safety
alerts a striking contrast from what
happened in nova scotia in april of 2020
where police communication about the
port-a-pick massacre has been the
subject of intense scrutiny and
criticism
multiple murders more than one crime
scene and an urgent manhunt
something too many canadians sadly have
seen before and it's especially familiar
for nova scotians there are sort of
eerie parallels in some ways to the
portapec tragedy that we experienced
here this professor emeritus at nova
scotia's dalhousie university says he's
struck by what's different the response
of saskatchewan rcmp much more what
we were hoping for in nova scotia in
terms of a major alert system
the blockading of various places the
cooperation between the local police and
the rcmp as well as the governments
after receiving a call about a stabbing
at 5 40 a.m local time saskatchewan rcmp
issued a dangerous persons alert to the
james smith cree nation at nearby
communities at 7 12 a.m followed by an
updated alert at 7 57 that included
pictures of the suspects another one at
8 20 to the entire province of
saskatchewan and then a fourth alert
province-wide at 9 45 a.m indicating
there were multiple victims in multiple
locations there was also a promise to
use tv radio and cell phones if
necessary to broadcast further alerts by
contrast nova scotia rcmp under-reported
the port-a-pick massacre limiting
communications in the early hours to a
tweet about an unspecified firearms
complaint they never did issue an
emergency alert something several
mouties at the mass casualty
commission's public inquiry admit they
never considered i'm betting it's just a
case of none of us thought of it because
none of us had seen it used in anything
but a weather capacity nova scotia
maudie's did encounter additional
obstacles evidence suggesting the gunman
might have died early on and then the
fact he was disguised as an officer
driving a full replica of an rcmp car
by the time the killer was found driving
a victim's car and gunned down he'd
killed 22 people including a pregnant
woman and an rcmp constable
chilling proof such manhunts can become
even more dangerous before they're over
ross lord global news
a swelling wildfire at a national park
in alberta coming up the warning to
residents there and visitors
overnight the chatham wildfire grew
again to cover some 8 000 hectares at
jasper national park the fire which
started on thursday is being described
as aggressive and even unsafe for ground
crews but rain and cooler temperatures
have started to help the situation the
fire is not threatening any communities
homes or businesses at the moment but it
has consumed a number of power poles
briefly cutting off electricity to the
municipality of jasper sunday night
while no evacuation orders or alerts are
in place residents and visitors in
jasper are being told to prepare for
more possible power outages
in northern california at least two
people are dead more than one thousand
others have been forced from their homes
due to the out-of-control mill wildfire
at least 100 structures will be
destroyed but crews say they are getting
the upper hand on the fire and they
don't expect any further spread
california like much of the western
united states has been experiencing a
severe and prolonged drought making for
extreme fire danger to washington state
now where the u.s coast guard says it's
suspending its search for nine missing
people including a child who were on a
small float plane that crashed in the
puget sound the aircraft went down
sunday afternoon one person has been
found dead the plane was flying from the
san juan islands near the border with
british columbia when witnesses say they
saw a nosedive into the waters northwest
of seattle the cause of the crash is now
under investigation
and a search and rescue operations
underway to find survivors of a powerful
earthquake in china's sichuan province
at least 46 people are confirmed dead in
the region that has millions living
under a covid 19 lockdown the 6.8
magnitude quake shook buildings and
triggered landslides sending boulders
rolling down from mountains onto
roadways over one thousand soldiers are
being deployed to the disaster stricken
area to help with the rescue efforts
meet britain's prime minister ahead can
liz trust shake off the baggage of her
old boss
weeks after the fbi raided donald
trump's mar-a-lago mansion seizing many
highly classified documents in his
possession
a trump-appointed federal judge has
granted his request for a special master
to review the materials the move will
delay the department of justice's probe
of the former u.s president on possible
obstruction of justice and violations of
the espionage act with the judge also
blocking the doj's review of sensitive
files until the watchdog's examination
is finished both trump's legal team and
the doj must now jointly submit a list
of candidates by friday and outlined
their duties and restrictions federal
prosecutors are expected to appeal the
decision
tomorrow newly minted uk conservative
leader liz truss will become the
country's new prime minister replacing
boris johnson this is the third change
of leader for the ruling conservatives
in just six years trust has served in a
number of top jobs in the british
cabinet and even spent a year for
childhood here in canada but as redmond
shannon reports she's facing a long list
of political problems and potential
crises
81 000 in a nation no stranger to
political drama this outcome came as
little shock liz truss is elected as the
leader of the conservative and unionist
party but the margin of liz truss's win
over former british finance minister
rishi sunak was tighter than some had
predicted 57 of conservative party
members to 43. i know
that we will deliver we will deliver and
we will deliver compared with boris
johnson trust can seem short on bombast
and charisma perhaps both a blessing and
a curse following the non-stop
controversy of boris's reign my first
priority is reducing taxes the outgoing
foreign secretary wooed the membership
with some typically tory promises but
these are anything but typical times war
in ukraine high inflation energy bills
surging industrial strikes and the still
unresolved headache of brexit truss
originally opposed the uk leaving the eu
but like predecessor theresa may she
flipped after the 2016 referendum a
young truss spent grade 7 in burnaby
british columbia calling it a year that
changed her outlook on life former
classmate and current teacher at the
same school brenda montagno recalls how
truss fit right in totally remember her
as elizabeth but no i have not been
tracking her so it was pretty exciting
and have certainly been googling her
since and very exciting to see the news
today years before becoming a
conservative a young trust addressed the
party convention of the centrist liberal
democrats arguing to abolish the
monarchy
we do not
believe that people should be born to
rule trust has since changed her
position on the monarchy too it's just
as well on tuesday morning she and
johnson fly to scotland to meet the
queen for trusses swearing in as leader
it's then back here to london where we
expect to hear more about the vision and
the policies of the uk's latest prime
minister redmond shannon global news
london
inflation and the war in ukraine are
also on the minds of eu leaders as
financial markets opened with the euro
hitting a 20-year low the fallen values
directly related to the rise in gas
prices following russia's decision to
stop the flow of natural gas through the
north stream one pipeline financial
analysts say they expect the euro to
drop even more the crisis is having a
ripple effect outside of europe too with
markets in australia china and the uk
also taking a hit
the separation nuclear power plant at
the center of tensions between russia
and ukraine has been taken offline once
again according to the plant's operator
shelling knocked out power to the last
working reactor on the site this follows
days of shelling over the weekend that
brought parts of the plant on and
offline last week inspectors from the
u.n nuclear agency were given access to
the plant and two inspectors are still
on site
next we go back to saskatchewan and more
from the grief stricken communities next
[Music]
sadly over these past years
tragedies
like these
have become all too commonplace
saskatchewanians and canadians
will do what we always do in times of
difficulty and anguish
we'll be there for each other
there is so much healing to do for
people in saskatchewan after yesterday's
devastating attacks let's go back to our
heather urex west who's in one of the
communities affected by the tragedy
heather you know we know that one of the
suspects is still at large i know you're
in this very tight-knit community
what's it like to be there i'm sure
people are still on edge
yeah people are on edge but you know
even even once this manhunt
winds down and we know that one suspect
is still at large
the people here are really having to
come to terms with such traumatic loss
one person
gone from this community of weld in
saskatchewan but in the nearby
james cree james smith crenation nine
lives have been lost i've spent you know
yesterday last night and today talking
with people in both communities and
people are just devastated there are
families in the james smith cree nation
that have lost multiple family members
and then they still have yet more
members that are in hospital some of
them fighting for their lives but farah
as well you know talking to so many of
these people i really get the sense
that people care deeply for one another
these are large extended families
everyone knows everyone these are dear
friends or relatives aunties uncles uh
brothers sisters and so people are
really
honoring each other's privacy and each
other's grief even as they grapple with
some really painful uh losses of their
own pharah
lives are being lost heather and lives
have been shattered just in the past
two days thank you so much that's
heather york's west in weldon
saskatchewan
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm farah nasser and we are
going to leave you tonight at the
saskatchewan legislative building in
regina where as you can see the flags
have been lowered at half mast in the
wake of this senseless tragedy that's
left 10 people dead and more than a
dozen people hurt thank you for watching
our donna friesen is going to be
broadcasting from saskatchewan tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]